we are a nation united if by anything by
mourning this morning as we mark half a
million lives lost in the pandemic
as you were just listening the bells of
washington's national cathedral told
yesterday
500 times once for every thousand
americans killed the white house has
ordered flags flown at half staff for
five days
and last night the bidens and the second
family held an emotional moment of
silence it is the first
official event ever at the white house
to honor those we've lost
wishes is at the white house this
morning for us wija good morning to you
as we were just saying joe biden knows
loss intimately spoke from the heart
directly to american families who have
lost someone
what was his message a good morning tony
you're right he
used exactly that his own personal pain
to empathize with others and while he
did honor the lives of the more than
half a million people lost
he also asked americans to repurpose
their grief
to prevent even more deaths today we
mark a
truly grim heartbreaking milestone
president biden said he felt he knew
those who died of coven 19
and certainly the heartache of their
loved ones
i know all too well i know what it's
like to not be there
when it happens the president's first
wife and baby daughter were killed in a
car crash
he lost his adult son beau to brain
cancer
i know what it's like when you are there
holding their hands just look in your
eye and they slip away
the somber ceremony was a departure from
former president
trump who did not hold a moment of
national mourning or a memorial service
but repeatedly downplayed the pandemic
we have it very much under control
it's not my fault that he came here it's
china's fault november 4th
you won't hear too much about it dr
anthony fauci on monday
seemed to partially blame the previous
administration for where we are now
i don't think it's you know all donald
trump or
all this or all that it's a combination
of things
and certainly the lack of involvement
at the very very top of the leadership
more than 44 million people in the u.s
have been vaccinated so far
putting the biden administration's goal
to vaccinate
100 million in 100 days within reach
as some states experience critical
vaccine shortages
mr biden signaled hope this nation will
smile again
this nation will know sunny days again
this nation will know joy again
and in a promising sign the acting fda
commissioner said the administration
is looking for ways to modify vaccines
and therapeutics to tackle those
variants of the virus that continue to
spread
gail all right weeja thank you very much